يمكن عشره بالميه او اقل اقل من عشره اقل
من عشره والسبب ليش يعني ليش ليش ما يكون
فيه نشاط اكبر في هذا المجال هو علم
الامريكي قله المتخصصين في هذا المجال ما
هو موقف شيء كمان ينحسب لنا صح احنا بدينا
متاخر لكن الحمد لله ما نهبت اثارنا لانه
تعرف اول مع الرحاله لمن يجون ومع التنقيب
كثير من الاثار انه هيبات فالحمد لله على
الاقل انه حتى لو متاخرين بس الحمد لله ما
نهبت اثارنا ما زالت موجوده عندنا
فمثلا لما نجي نشوف مساحه المملكه صح
للامانه نحتاج عدد اكبر من البعثات
الاثريه الدوليه الموجوده وفي من هالمه زي
مثلا معهد ماكس بلانك الالماني عمل كذا
دراسه كذا بعثه اثريه والمميزه كلها
موجوده في موقعهم كل الدراسات اللي عملوها
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه منها اقدم من
الجهه المانيه ايوه وفي عندك كمان فرنسيه
وايطاليا مثلا تعاقد هيئه التراث لتنقيب
الاثار الغارقه وهذا كمان شيء مهم عندنا
في البحر فهذا كمان جزء مهم لانه عندك
مثلا
الموانئ القديمه وغيرها موجوده كلها هذه
البحر كيف صار يعني في البحر الاحمر او في
الخليج العربي اعمال تنقيبيه لا حسب علمي
ما صار لنا الان تم التعاقد السنه اللي
فاتت مع جامعه نابولي لان عندك موانع
قديمه لنا الانباط كمان وصلوا لايطاليا
لهم معابد فهذا اللي بس نعرفه عن الامراض
يمكن في عصور قديمه كانت لانه تعرف قبل كم
مليون سنه نقول الطبيعه كانت تختلف فايش
راح نلقى تحت البحر هذا كمان انظمه من
الاشياء بالمستقبل ان شاء الله راح تغير
كمان مجرى التاريخ زي مثلا السنه اللي
فاتت غيرنا مجرى التاريخ في اكتشاف واحد
وهذا الجميل بعلم الاثار ان انت ما عندك
كتاب معين ترجع له دائما حسب اخر اكتشاف
يتغير